mm a little bit of this
now a little bit of that I'm gonna get
this party [__] started on the Lord's
Day you understand me it's a beautiful
[__] day to be alive people
understand me
August 5th you're ready to [__] rock
tip-top Magoo you understand I got two
little better weeds in town I'm feeling
good I'm looking good and that's all
that matters you know I'm saying as long
as I stop me yes still works
you're [__] solid
what are you [__] nuts or what uncle
Joey here coming to you direct on the
Lord's Day with some Sunday morning
[__] hot Fiat and balls you
understand me I just left Church I had
the cookie I got the [__] out of there
7:30 man where am I
I'm with you [__] that
attention you understand me not [__]
around I got the weed that TJ Dillashaw
smoked last night up
Kobe God brat that [__] love you but
you know I'm saying all those tattoos
went to waste what the [__] uncle Joey
here hey up there indeed are you two you
two [__] we got a great week
coming up don't forget the podcast we'll
be ready for you at 8 a.m. tomorrow
morning maybe even six I'm gonna get Lee
back on the [__] mule we got Kansas
City I'm [__] Thursday night ready to
rock eight o'clock
don't don't [__] up the mule is already
on the way look at this what we gotta
have we got some [__] kirova boom
this red stuff here is taking a [__]
Zambo ville and we got this old G from
ker over another 28 percent I don't take
you to fine I'll see your grandmother
spirit with no brawn you ever say you'll
see a grandma with no brawn it's a
[__] up situation but from time to
time when you smoke good weed it pops up
anyway Joey what's with the [__]
chili channel let's park this
[__] you guys to get the full
effect of your [__] uncle yeah I'm
saying anyway we got this one up first
why not it's the Lord's eligos eight
o'clock most people in bed [__] dream
and finger banging their brain with luck
from what they're gonna do what they're
not gonna do I've been up since 6:00 I
was at the [__] comedy store last
night Oh [__] fan 30 and then I
stopped at my buddy's house professor
Brent and we smoked the [__] blunt
that that when I got home I did a little
riding and I went to bed I'm up at 6:00
a.m. right and getting ready for my
[__] family getting ready dog 55
years old still swinging dick what's
your [__] excused
up off that [__] couch I'm at the
Comedy Store again you understand I
don't know if you've seen it the
economy's for the last two or three
weeks listen it's over what I was [__]
around with me whatever concerns I had
would have empathy I had with the
audience it's over
I've been going off lately like a
[__] savage up on stage and I love it
why there's always a member if you want
to be the best you gotta hang out with
the best and metal sharpens [__]
metal playing and [__] simple no more
and you won't see me anywhere else in LA
but the [__] Comedy Store every night
following guys they Rogen Chris D'Elia
you wanna follow [__] heat try
following Chris D'Elia Kyle Dunnigan
last night
[__] rogue and run white that's Sam
trippi's my brother my Armenian death
[__] killer over there but we'll
enjoy wave dropping names on a Sunday
I'm sorry anyway you know what I love
you [__] it doesn't I'm trying
to tell you is they told them listen
I've seen the light 28 years you're not
gonna stop me I got the place I got a
couple guns stashed in case anybody
wants to come down and leave there
looking like a [__] Kennedy with half
a head you understand me we're ready to
rock [__] so bring it but as
far as everything else Joey what's with
the [__] a beating let's park a
little bit that's what I say
it's like a magic trick you understand
me
when you smoke we uncle Joey it's like a
[__] magic to come outside look at
this
it's a Snoop Dogg type of [__] and these
app just want to step up uncle Joey are
you kidding me
just the experience alone you'll crumble
on the [__] pressure you [__] much
uncle Joey listen I went to church and I
realized one thing I'm a Catholic and I
believe in all his ship you don't want
the church is my heart the church is in
my [__] nut sack and that's all that
matters the Joey
let's keep suckin sparking hey you want
to know why I'm a savage because I'm up
at six I already got two plane tickets I
got my [__] Boston plane ticket for
the Wilbur in Connecticut and today I
got my [__] how bout to Philly to the
parks casino and then the DC to the 9:30
club what are you [__] nuts
September 15th or something like the
Helen Helen listen no dates I don't know
no dates yeah I know is this bump in
Thursday Kansas City I work or what's in
front of me you follow me like that and
nice and easy I got a couple things to
do able to go to the forty and all the
[__] jujitsu roll then I'm gonna come
back the family's gonna be in church I'm
gonna do another little some [__]
ready and stop over and help out a
friend we got to go do a wraparound for
your podcast too mama
then I'm [__] done I got a little
barbecue this afternoon but some girls
the girls are gonna [__] come over we
got like play dates with kids can you
imagine uncle Joey I'll put Visine in my
eyes but it don't matter
I'm a [__] Savage I'm watching out
like a [__] like an eagle you
understand me Joey
you gonna spark pleasing a [__] talk
listen relax this [__] leaf I guess
your little psyche putting the [__]
quarter in saying give me somebody a
plastic cook that's I'm good this
[__] rain forest even get somebody a
blaster coach or do blaster code you
have a smacking place to [__] pop and
ten times to shut the [__] up anyway
look at this one think of two la cops
last night nicest [__] people in the
world and I got an ant in my pocket and
some [__] rolling papers I'm having a
conversation with them about policing in
the area [__] like that I love it
I love that but your uncle Joey's here
[__] never fear cuz you know I
love you I love you mother [__] what
are you guys like a nun the reason why
I'm employed on stage is because of you
[__] and as we get along I'll
tell you more stories but Joey boy I'm a
fool my lack of compile or hips with the
guy oh look at that the lung of debt
Isis captures me and tries to smoke me
out they're done they take the hoods off
its overjoyed we're going back to run
with the [__] Christians it's all
over and that's it and that's that I
just wanted to check on you
[__] on the Lord's Day and let
you know oh yes the mplet that didn't
get my my dad to was I forget book a do
he what kill you evil eye Santi SEMA car
your body your Google Panda laughs wait
am i I will choose your meal look at 10
lucky oye Bhutan they throw buyer well
our people let's smoke another one child
so you don't say something I enjoy for
10 minutes only smoke two balls no no no
no we go deep here put all the yeah
7:24 in the words of my stepfather what
happened here what happened here I get
my son hopper here nothing happened you
know what happened here [__] massacre
remember this is the church and we're
family till the end I'm with you you
with me and these little punk-ass
[__] want to be with us but they got
the boss I catch him at the border late
Trump get him Sam anyway we're here
we're queer
I'm happy you [__] join me on a
Sunday morning 8 o'clock in the [__]
morning who does this type of [__]
[__] us
because we don't give a [__] what a
misfits and we know it you don't see me
over here talking my friends like I know
what I'm talking about I'm gonna go to
France and hang myself suck my dick
I'm here in Southern California from
North Bergen New Jersey not giving a
[__] aka Hudson County Hoboken
representing Jacey representing [__]
West New York representing [__] Union
City I'm a [__] around you bad bad
[__] you got me all fired up on
the Lord's Day I love it
let's do one more [__] ball like I
said when you're looking for the Reetha
sign seller that's the only Armenians I
run with eyes are go [__] they start
twitching you like least I started that
the taxes anyway gets don't like this
only [__] savages hate the morning
with their favorite [__] nephews who
does this we do because we don't give a
[__] that didn't come imagine up being a
higher
pilot to Bombardier there goes one eye
I'm saying there goes one I said when
you come to somebody's eye the [__] I
won't stop twitching the same [__]
deal
pilot the Bombardier anyway I love you
[__] you know it I know it I'm
having a good time I'm 55 you guys are
keeping me alive you guys are keeping me
in check no [__] given that's it when
you come to one of my shows now the
safety net has been removed what they
gonna [__] psychological right who
gives a [__]
let's talk about what's really going on
outstanding all those tattoos for
nothing I still got it anyway I can't
come to Europe you know I got no [__]
paperwork and if I applied for paperwork
they're gonna know I'm here and we got
more problems come over here take a
[__] strip and cut the [__] [__] I
can't go to you I can't go nowhere I
gotta sit here
you don't saying every time I take a
flight the [__] warning light goes
off I don't know what the [__] I'm going
here trying to they give me pre TSA you
know me I got the [__] clear I put my
balls on the thing everybody knows one
man but for right now let's stay right
here in the United States just in case
they don't let me back in what if they
don't let me back in woman I like what
am I gonna go you're gonna take me in
over in Europe don't want me
maybe the Canadians the Canadians
they'll take anybody they'll take me
they do [__] people in Canadians you
know how to party a family up there
cashes Morris I got some friends up
there anyway Anthony Spain and I'll see
you in Kansas City I'm coming in heavy
Joey falada showing up he's driving from
st. Louis I got two mules on the way
where that at Bulls explore and forget
about it
I got a [__] with a bow and arrow
we're [__] around
I'm showing up with a big dick a lot of
personality and a lot of heart and I'm
saying so get ready to rock
[__] your podcast will be ready
tomorrow you will have a new week
whatever happened last week at the last
week don't worry about it grab the
notebook and write down what you want to
happen this week navigate your [__]
life stop waiting for somebody you're
knockin on your door give you a package
cuz I got bad news for a nobody gonna
give you a dick not in this [__]
society get up get up water in your face
spray cologne on that [__] dick and
get out there get out there get a knife
I don't give a [__] what you gotta do if
I see the 7-eleven begging for money
I'll spit in your face you're a man yeah
your dignity together you know saying
get dignity together get up get out
there get out there stop with the
excuses are not gonna hide and I see
plenty of people no hablo that get
[__] hired you just don't want to
work [__] get your [__] life
together uncle Joey coming at you on the
Sun there I'm a mom with you you're with
me and they wanna be with us the Church
of what's happening now loud and [__]
clear you'll have your podcast tomorrow
morning and that's it stop lying to
yourself and walk then take what belongs
to you all right it's that simple
uncle Joey they didn't get my might
they'll bring her today all this [__]
fifth stay black